This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二（Guaranteed Human. 2%）。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身以及建立恢复力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就能破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的更好的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字的2%，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或您收听播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学步》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在跟一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，你就非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA Radio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学步》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们的含义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. Wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we begin, I just want to let you know that this episode is actually a collab episode with my other podcast mantra.
对于我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众。无论你身在世界何处，很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要剖析20多岁的心理学。在开始之前，我只想让大家知道，这一期其实是我另一个播客《曼特拉》（Mantra）的合作节目。
So if you would like a more succinct, spiritually minded version, of this episode to get you started before. We dive into the psychology and the research. Do check it out. I'll leave a link in the description. But as for our subject matter today, we are diving into a topic that I think everyone has experienced in some way or another,
所以，如果你想要一个更简明、更具精神层面的版本，在……在我们深入探讨心理学和研究之前，先听听这一集来作为热身。请务必去看看。我会在简介中留下链接。但就我们今天的主题而言，我们正在深入探讨一个我认为每个人在某种程度上都经历过的话题，
even if you don't always want to admit it, something that can kind of simmer in the background for days, for months, sometimes years. We are talking about grudges. I'll be honest. And I don't feel great admitting this, but I have held grudges for like a decade, for many, many years.
即使你并不总是愿意承认这一点，有些事情可能会在背景中酝酿几天、几个月，有时甚至是几年。我们谈论的是记仇。老实说。我承认这一点感觉并不太好，但我已经记仇大约十年了，很多很多年。
Even after a person is long gone from my life, even after I'm sure they have grown and they have matured, as have I, there is this lingering feeling of anger and resentment that has stayed and that comes up from time to time. The thing is, I know for a fact I'm not alone. I know for a fact that none of us are innocent of this because holding grudges, well, it turns out, surprise, surprise, is a lot more universal and human than we think and is linked to some very core human behaviors. So today, I really want to ask the question, what are those core behaviors? Why do we hold grudges? What purpose do they serve?
即使一个人早已从我的生活中消失，即使我确信他们已经成长、成熟，正如我也一样，那种挥之不去的愤怒和怨恨的感觉依然留存着，并不时涌现出来。关键是，我非常清楚我并不孤单。我很清楚我们中没有人能对此清白，因为记仇，嗯，事实证明，出乎意料的是，它比我们想象的要更普遍、更具人性，并且与一些非常核心的人类行为有关。所以今天，我真的很想问这样一个问题，这些核心行为是什么？我们为什么会记仇？它们有什么用？
And more importantly, what do they actually secretly reveal about our emotional needs, our relationships? and the story of our life that we are almost telling ourselves because underneath this resentment, underneath this kind of bitterness, there's usually something deeper and quite soft that we don't want to acknowledge. You know, there is a boundary that was crossed.
更重要的是，它们到底暗中揭示了我们的哪些情感需求、我们的人际关系？以及我们几乎在对自己讲述的人生故事，因为在这种怨恨的背后，在这种所谓的苦涩背后，通常有一些更深层、相当柔软的东西，是我们不想承认的。你知道，有一条界限被超越了。
There is a part of you that felt unseen. There is a story that you haven't finished telling. And that's why the grudge stays, even where it doesn't really seem to serve a purpose anymore. This part of you that, has felt hurt or injured just really isn't ready to let it go because they still don't feel like they have closure. And when we understand this lack of closure as a reason for our resentment and as a reason for holding on to grudges, we understand them a lot better and in a more complex way that
你身上有一部分觉得自己没有被看见。有一个你还没讲完的故事。这就是为什么怨恨会留下来，甚至在它似乎不再有任何用处的时候也是如此。你身上这部分曾经感到受伤或受到伤害的人，真的还没有准备好放手，因为他们仍然觉得没有得到一个了结。当我们理解这种缺乏了结感作为我们怨恨的原因，以及作为我们记仇的原因时，我们会更好地理解它们，并以一种更复杂的方式去理解它，
goes beyond just forgiveness or black and white thinking. You know, this person was the villain, this person was the victim. This person was good. This person was bad. Nothing. ever is that simple when humans are involved and this topic is included grudges are included in that matter so whether you are nursing a silent grudge or you're just trying to figure out how to stop feeling this kind of anger towards someone else how to process the pain if you're wondering should I let go or maybe should I hold on a little bit longer this episode is most certainly for you Today, let's unpack the psychology of grudges and why they seem to matter to us. Stay with us.
超越单纯的宽恕或非黑即白的思维。你知道，这个人是恶棍，这个人是受害者。这个人是好的。这个人是坏的。当涉及到人类时，没有什么事情是那么简单的，这个话题也包括在内，记仇也包含在那个问题中。所以无论你是在暗自怨恨，还是只是在试图弄清楚如何停止对另一个人产生这种愤怒，如何处理痛苦，如果你在想我应该放下，还是应该再坚持一会儿，这一期节目绝对适合你。今天，让我们来剖析记仇的心理学以及它们为什么对我们如此重要。请继续关注。
So let's get something very, very clear. What is a grudge really and what is it not? What's different about a grudge compared to a fleeting moment of anger or sadness is the persistence of the feeling. It is this persistent feeling of resentment or malice that is a result of. from a past insult, a past offense that actively lingers and does not go away. Psychologically, a grudge involves one core ingredient, and that core ingredient is active rumination. That is that for something to be a grudge, we have to be repeatedly dwelling on
所以让我们把一些事情弄得非常非常清楚。记仇到底是什么，它又不是什么？记仇与短暂的愤怒或悲伤不同之处在于这种感觉的持久性。这是一种挥之不去的怨恨或恶意的感觉，它是由过去的侮辱、过去的冒犯所导致的，并且积极地挥之不去，不会消失。从心理学上讲，记仇包含一个核心成分，而这个核心成分就是积极反刍。也就是说，要想构成记仇，我们必须反复琢磨
the offense, repeatedly analyzing it from every angle, re-experiencing the negative emotions associated with it for it to have the kind of hold that it does over us. It's not simply, I haven't forgotten. It's I haven't forgotten and emotionally I'm still bothered by it and that's why it feels like it matters. A 2021 study conducted by researchers at York University in England, they theorized that the act of holding a grudge is actually a cyclical process that is characterized by negative emotions and intrusive thoughts that continue to kind of trigger each other and impact our quality
这种冒犯，从各个角度反复分析它，重新体验与之相关的负面情绪，它才能对我们产生这种控制力。这不仅仅是“我没有忘记”。而是“我没有忘记，并且在情感上我仍然为此困扰”，这就是为什么它感觉如此重要。2021年由英国约克大学的研究人员进行的一项研究，他们从理论上推测，记仇的行为实际上是一个循环过程，其特征是负面情绪和侵入性思维，它们继续相互触发并影响我们的生活质量
of life. Participants in the study, they conveyed that whilst the intensity of the negative thoughts and the emotions may dwindle over time, the underlying negativity connected to that memory or event is always kind of in the background. It is always ready to be summoned like at any point. So whilst grudges don't necessarily have to be all consuming every single day, there is a negativity there that is lying dormant and is
。参与研究的参与者表达说，虽然负面想法和情绪的强度可能会随着时间的推移而减弱，但与该记忆或事件相关的潜在消极情绪总是潜伏在背景中。它随时准备被召唤，就像在任何时候一样。因此，虽然记仇不一定每天都占据全部，但那里确实存在一种潜伏的负面情绪，并且当它觉得自己将发挥作用时，
very much ready to be reignited when it feels like it's going to serve a purpose. So there are a few compelling reasons why our mind might default to holding on rather than letting go. The first is that some people
它随时准备被重新点燃。因此，有几个令人信服的原因，为什么我们的心灵可能会默认坚持而不是放手。首先是有些人
just unfortunately have a harder time releasing, resentment. It's just in their personality. According to research published in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology, individuals high in neuroticism, which is a personality trait that's very similar to anxiety, they are more likely to ruminate on negative experiences, making it harder for them to move on or harder for them to reframe those events in a neutral light, meaning that they have a higher collection, higher prevalence of grouches. A similar study also found that people with an insecure attachment style are also more prone to grudges
不幸的是，他们就是更难释放怨恨。这只是他们的性格使然。根据发表在《人格与社会心理学杂志》（Journal of Personality and Social Psychology）上的研究，神经质得分高的人——这是一种非常类似于焦虑的人格特质——他们更有可能对消极经历进行反刍，这使得他们更难释怀，或者更难在中立的光照下重新构建这些事件，这意味着他们会有更高的记仇积累和更高的普遍性。一项类似的研究还发现，具有不安全依恋风格的人也更容易记仇，
and also individuals with ADHD, particularly people whose ADHD presents itself through a strong sense of justice and fairness or who have rejection sensitivity disorder RSD alongside their ADHD. I was reading about this on Reddit actually the other day and it's a Reddit page for women with ADHD and there were literally hundreds of individuals talking about small slides from years ago or decades ago that they just couldn't let go of that they really wanted to and all of them said it got worse when the ADHD symptoms got worse as well so it seemed kind of connected to a larger cluster of things that were going on now this is still an area of emerging research But it could be one part of the explanation for you if you feel like compared to friends,
还有患有多动症（ADHD）的个体，特别是那些多动症表现为对正义和公平有强烈感官，或者除了多动症之外还患有拒绝敏感性 dysphoria（RSD）的人。其实前几天我在Reddit上读到过这个，那是一个专为患有多动症的女性设立的Reddit页面，里面有成百上千的人在谈论几年前或几十年前的小轻蔑，他们就是无法释怀，他们真的很想释怀，而且所有人都说，当多动症症状恶化时，情况变得更糟了，所以这似乎与正在发生的一系列更大的事情有关。现在这仍然是一个新兴研究领域，但如果你觉得跟朋友、
compared to relatives, grudges just sit heavier with you compared to them. On a more general level, I think the reason that humans in general seem hardwired towards remembering over forgetting is because our memory and our ability to recall specific events, it's not particularly honest or objective. It is highly selective. it is a strategically biased filter. We remember only what emotionally resonates with us, but we of course also only remember it from our perspective
跟亲戚相比，记仇对你来说更沉重，这可能是对你的一种解释。在一个更普遍的层面上，我认为人类普遍似乎天生就倾向于记住而不是忘记，是因为我们的记忆以及我们回忆特定事件的能力并不是特别诚实或客观。它是高度选择性的。它是一个具有战略偏见的过滤器。我们只记得那些在情感上与我们共鸣的事情，但当然，我们也只从我们的视角去记住它
and through the lens with which we originally viewed or experiencing something happening. So there's no way to tell what the objective truth is. Your opinion is always going to be involved. We also tend to remember pain and negative experiences more vividly and more persistently than ones that are positive or ones that involve pleasure. So this is known in psychology, specifically in cognitive psychology as a negativity bias. Almost all of us have this, pessimistic, optimistic, whatever you are.
，并通过我们最初看待或经历某事发生的视角。所以没有办法判断客观真理是什么。你的意见总是会参与其中。我们往往也比那些积极的或带来快乐的经历更生动、更持久地记住痛苦和消极经历。这在心理学中，特别是在认知心理学中被称为消极偏见。几乎我们所有人都有这种倾向，无论你是悲观主义者、乐观主义者还是其他什么人。
There is a part of you from an evolutionary standpoint that will always prefer to remember negative things over positive things. Think about it this way. It was much more important for you, as I do. ancient human to know where the poisonous snake lived or to know where the predator lurked rather than to know where the berries grew. Yes, the berries are nice and they're lovely, but the snake and the predator, they are the thing that is really going to cost you. This was really crucial for our survival. Our ancestors who quickly learned from negative encounters were more likely
从进化的角度来看，你身上总有一部分人会更愿意记住消极的事情而不是积极的事情。想想看。作为一个古代人类，知道毒蛇住在哪里或者知道掠夺者潜伏在哪里，比知道浆果长在哪里要重要得多。是的，浆果很好，它们很可爱，但是蛇和掠夺者，它们才是真正会让你付出代价的东西。这对于我们的生存至关重要。我们的祖先如果能从消极的遭遇中迅速吸取教训，就更有可能
to live another day. Of course, environmental information isn't the only thing that's important social information is also really valuable to us. So the dangers that may have been present back in ancient times are present in a new form. They're more present socially and through what we perceive as social threats. So if someone wrongs us, if someone does something that really hurts us, that feels not just painful but threatening. And so it gets tagged in our memory storage system as a high priority. Because it has been tagged that way, it is encoded with a greater emotional intensity. It triggers stronger psychological response and is therefore in the future more easily recalled,
多活一天。当然，环境信息并不是唯一重要的东西，社交信息对我们也非常有价值。因此，古代可能存在的危险正以一种新的形式存在。它们在社交层面上以及通过我们视为社交威胁的事物更加明显。所以如果有人冤枉了我们，如果有人做了真正伤害我们的事，那不仅感觉痛苦，而且感觉具有威胁性。因此，它在我们的记忆存储系统中被标记为高优先级。因为它被这样标记了，它就被赋予了更强的情感强度编码。它会触发更强的心理反应，因此在未来更容易被召回，
especially when we encounter similar situations or we encounter similar people or even when we just encounter internal triggers. Beyond just, you know, memory and the strangeness of our memory systems as humans, holding a grudge can feel like a vital act of self-protection. If someone hurt you deeply in the past, your mind might cling to that resentment as a really powerful psychological shield, but also as an emotional barrier that is designed to prevent future pain. It's often this very deceptive internal declaration that says, if I continue to be angry, it means that this isn't going to happen again because I will be on guard and I will know to be prepared for it. Clinging to the grudge kind of ensures that you don't forget the bitter lesson that you
特别是当我们遇到类似情况或遇到类似的人，甚至当我们只是遇到内部触发因素时。除了你懂的，记忆以及人类记忆系统的奇异之处之外，记仇可以感觉像是一种至关重要的自我保护行为。如果过去有人深深地伤害了你，你的心灵可能会紧紧抓住这种怨恨，将其作为一种非常强大的心理盾牌，同时也作为一个旨在防止未来痛苦的情感屏障。这通常是一个非常具有欺骗性的内部宣言，上面写着：“如果我继续生气，就意味着这不会再次发生，因为我会保持警惕，我会知道如何为此做好准备。”紧抓怨恨某种程度上确保了你不会忘记你从不公正中学到的痛苦教训
learn from the injustice and as a result, you continue to be hyper aware of future potential threats. So you save yourself. You stop yourself from being naive. You stop yourself from trusting too easily and therefore you stop yourself from experiencing pain. It's actually quite sad when you think about it, you know, one bad egg, one bad fruit, I think, what's the saying? One bad, bad fruit spoils the whole bunch. One bad human who does something terrible might make you hypervigilant for the rest of your life. For some, I think it also, again, helps you reinforce a necessary boundary. The fact that the grudge is still there means that you'll never let this person back into your life because you have a constant reminder of how they made you feel. This can be a very
，因此，你会继续对未来潜在的威胁保持高度警惕。所以你拯救了你自己。你阻止自己变得天真。你阻止自己轻易信任，因此你阻止自己经历痛苦。当你仔细想想时，其实这相当可悲，你知道的，一颗老鼠屎，一个坏水果，我想，那句话怎么说来着？一颗坏果子坏了一筐。一个做可怕事情的坏人可能会让你在余生中都处于高度警觉状态。对于某些人来说，我认为这也再次帮助你强化了一个必要的界限。怨恨依然存在的事实意味着你永远不会让这个人回到你的生活中，因为你有一个不断提醒他们如何让你感受到的常态。这可以成为一个
genuinely adaptive behavior in the case of harmful or abusive relationships where, you know, maintaining no contact is crucial for safety. However, the same mechanism can become maladaptive when it kind of keeps everyone out, when it stops you from letting there be new opportunities for genuine connection, for empathy, for positive healing experiences with people who aren't going to hurt you. Well, you know, the intention is undeniable. perhaps a good one, and it is protective, I think the long-term effect can be profoundly self-isolating. You know, we do possess a very primal need for justice. The thing that really contributes to this is what we know as the just world hypothesis. Basically, beyond just wanting to protect ourselves,
在有害或虐待关系中真正具适应性的行为，在那里，你知道保持零接触对安全至关重要。然而，当它把所有人都挡在外面，当它阻止你为那些不会伤害你的人提供真正的联系、同理心、积极的治愈经历的新机会时，同样的机制就会变得适应不良。好吧，你知道，这种意图是不可否认的，或许是一个好的意图，而且它是具有保护性的，我认为长期的影响可能是深刻的自我孤立。你知道，我们确实拥有对正义的强烈需求。真正促成这一点的是我们所知的公正世界假说。基本上，除了想要保护我们自己之外，
we all kind of want to believe deep down that the world is fundamentally fair and that people generally they get what they deserve. If they do bad things, bad things will come back to them. If they're good and kind, the world will be good and kind to them. When a profound or seemingly arbitrary injustice happens to us, when someone does something bad and they get away with it, it really shatters this comforting illusion and that is what causes us to feel even worse and to perhaps question life in a way that's kind of distressing. You know, if someone does something bad to you and they get away with it, suddenly you're thinking, what's the point of me being good?
我们内心深处都倾向于相信，世界本质上是公平的，人们通常会得到他们应得的。如果他们做了坏事，坏事就会降临到他们头上。如果他们善良友善，世界也会对他们善良友善。当一种深刻的或看似任意的不公正发生在我们身上时，当某人做了坏事却逃脱惩罚时，它真的粉碎了这种令人欣慰的幻想，这正是导致我们感觉更糟糕并以某种令人痛苦的方式质疑生活的原因。你知道，如果有人对你做了坏事却逃脱了惩罚，你突然会想，我做好人还有什么意义？
If they get to be awful and still get a good life, why am I trying so hard to be good? Wouldn't it be easier to just not care about other people? Wouldn't it be easier to just not be good? Obviously, we don't all want to think that way. So holding a grudge can be kind of, a subconscious antidote to that discomfort. Me holding a grudge, me not forgetting, that is their punishment.
如果他们变得很糟糕却依然能过上好日子，为什么我要这么努力去做好人？不去在乎别人不是更轻松吗？不做个好人不是更轻松吗？显然，我们并非都想那样思考。所以，记恨在某种程度上可以算是一种对抗这种不适感的潜意识解毒剂。我记恨，我没有忘记，这就是对他们的惩罚。
That means that karma has worked because there is this like lingering thought that I have about them that is sitting over their head. We feel like the world is fair again because somewhere in your brain, they haven't gotten away with it. So in some ways holding a grudge can be a very desperate if ultimately futile attempt to return the world to how you think it should operate and how, you know, we want it to operate. It returns a very fragile sense of internal order. I think potentially the most deceptive reason and one of the final reasons we hold onto grudges
这意味着因果报应起作用了，因为我脑海中挥之不去地盘旋着一个关于他们的念头，就悬在他们的头顶。我们觉得世界又恢复公平了，因为在你的脑海深处，他们并没有逃脱惩罚。所以在某种程度上，记恨可能是一种非常绝望（如果最终是徒劳的话）的尝试，试图让世界回到你认为它应该运转的方式，以及，你知道的，我们希望它运转的方式。它恢复了一种非常脆弱的内在秩序感。我认为这可能是最具有欺骗性的原因之一，也是我们执着于记恨的最终原因之一，
comes from the fact that it provides a sense of control and that's where all these explanations are kind of leading. When an injustice occurs and we feel utterly vulnerable, that's a very, very shaky feeling. It's a very uncomfortable feeling. And it can make us really, again, ask some very big questions of the world. How could this happen? You know, how does, how does this person get to hurt me and get away with it? How was this allowed to occur? Do I really have any sense of control? You know, the answer is you probably don't. But if you cling to the resentment and you cling to the grudge, again, it reinforces that perhaps you can do something about it. It's also the same reason why we may replay over and over again hypothetical confrontations
它源于这样一个事实：它提供了一种掌控感，而这正是所有这些解释最终指向的地方。当不公正的事情发生，而我们感到彻底无助时，那是一种非常、非常动摇的感觉。那是一种极度不舒服的感觉。它真的会再次让我们对这个世界提出一些非常重大的疑问。这怎么可能发生？你知道的，这个人凭什么伤害了我却能逍遥法外？怎么能允许这种事发生？我真的有任何掌控感吗？你知道，答案是你可能没有。但如果你紧抓着怨恨不放，紧抓着记恨不放，这再次强化了这样一种可能：你或许能对此做点什么。这也是为什么我们可能会一遍又一遍地重演假设中的对峙，
or pretend arguments that you might have with this person. These illusions, these imaginations provide, once again, a powerful but illusory belief that we are still dictating this narrative. But here's the stark and kind of undeniable reality. We may feel like we're in control with a grudge. We may feel like it's protecting us. We may feel like it's justice. But in reality, a grudge is always going to harm us far more and far more consistently
或者假装你可能会和这个人进行的争论。这些幻觉、这些想象再次提供了一种强大但虚幻的信念，即我们仍然在掌控着这个叙事。但这里有一个残酷且不可否认的现实。带着记恨，我们可能会觉得自己掌控了一切。我们可能会觉得它在保护我们。我们可能会觉得这就是正义。但实际上，记恨总是会给我们带来远比对最初的目标更大、更持久的伤害，
than it's going to harm the original target. It sucks. But the fact is, is that the true pain of resentment is not one that someone else can feel it as one that we are going to feel the full force of ourselves. And so with that in mind, there has to be a healthier approach to this. Knowing all the reasons that we hold a grudge, despite all those reasons, there has to be something that we can do about it, surely. Well, that's exactly what we're going to talk about.
大得多也持久得多。这很糟糕。但事实是，怨恨真正的痛苦并不是别人能感受到的，而是我们要由自己承受其全部力量的痛苦。因此，考虑到这一点，必须有一种更健康的应对方法。了解了我们记恨的所有原因之后，尽管有种种原因，肯定还有我们可以做的事情。好吧，这正是我们要谈论的内容。
We're also going to talk about, again, how the resentment and the pain of a grudge does actually physically harm us and why that's something to be aware of. when you find yourself stewing after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience.
我们还将再次讨论，记恨所带来的怨恨和痛苦实际上是如何在生理上伤害我们的，以及为什么在经历这次短暂的休息后，当你发现自己还在为此耿耿于怀时，应该意识到这一点。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等对话，穿透那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学，
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这些伪科学充斥着健康产业。我们曾深信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击金·卡戴珊的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟金·卡戴珊到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day But just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack So I'm starting to see that there's a through line
包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔做客，大谈80年代的霹雳瘾（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为霹雳瘾。我随时准备谈论霹雳瘾，但为了让大家知道，马克，这是我们第二集讨论霹雳瘾了，所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。
We also have AIDS on the table right now So Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years For black people in American history
我们现在还把爱滋病摆在台面上，所以，谢谢你补全了那句话。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地成为一个好人。和我（基尔·盖恩斯）一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct?
打开你免费的I-Heart Radio应用，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法院诉讼序幕，以证明真相。你曾多次篡改过这个特定的检测结果，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the Westby and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·韦斯特比和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义于亚利桑那州得到伸张之前，这一切还远没有结束。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
podcasts. Okay, so the question that we have for this part of the show is how do Grudges kind of linger in our bodies in invisible but still painful ways? I saw this interview with none other than Miley Cyrus the other day, super random. You probably didn't think that her name was going to show up in this episode, but here we are. Anyways, Miley Cyrus, she's doing this interview and she's talking about how she has all this rage and she had all this resentment and she had all these grudges towards people who had wronged her. And she didn't let herself get angry about it.
好吧，那么我们在这部分节目中要探讨的问题是，记恨是如何以无形但仍然痛苦的方式在我们的身体里挥之不去的？前几天我看到这个采访，采访对象不是别人，正是麦莉·赛勒斯，超级随性。你可能没想到她的名字会出现在这一集里，但我们就是这样。不管怎样，麦莉·赛勒斯在接受采访时谈到，她内心充满了愤怒，她对那些冤枉过她的人有着所有的怨恨和记恨。而她并没有让自己去为此感到愤怒。
She just let them stew. And after a while, she was noticing that there was all this pain showing up in her body, pain that she didn't understand for years. And she realized that that pain was coming from the fact that she never let her. feel the full emotion behind her resentment. She wasn't able to let it go because she hadn't had that release. This is a great example of what a grudge can do. Now obviously a celebrity experience is one thing, but she is a real person and how she explained it really resonated with me because so many people feel this way but can't express it. She had the platform to be able to explain what she was experiencing and what she's experiencing. It's called somatization. And it's a term
她只是任由它们在心中发酵。过了一段时间，她注意到自己的身体开始出现各种疼痛，这些疼痛是她多年来一直无法理解的。她意识到，这些疼痛源于这样一个事实：她从未让自己去感受怨恨背后的全部情绪。她之所以无法放下，是因为她没有得到那种释放。这是一个很好的例子，说明了记恨能做什么。现在很显然，名人的经历是一回事，但她是一个真人，她如何解释这一点真的引起了我的共鸣，因为有太多人有这种感觉却无法表达。她拥有能够解释自己正在经历的事情的平台，而她所经历的，
that has been around for over a hundred years and it describes how our body actually harbors, feels and is pained by emotions we don't release, i.e. a grudge, i.e., back to what we're talking about today. There was a paper written about this a few decades back, actually in the late 90s, so a little bit dated now, but still relevant. And it talks about this exact experience and all these instances where medical professionals will encounter someone who has chronic pain who is suffering and they'll do all the blood work, they'll look at all the obvious biological signs of stress and of pain and there aren't any. There is no reasonable explanation for it. But then this person goes to therapy. This person starts talking about their rage,
被称为躯体化（somatization）。这个术语已经存在了一百多年，它描述了我们的身体实际上是如何储藏、感知那些我们没有释放的情绪，并因之而感到痛苦——也就是记恨，也就是回到我们今天讨论的话题。几十年前其实有一篇关于这方面的论文，大约在90年代末，所以现在有点过时了，但仍然具有相关性。它谈到了这种确切的经历以及所有这些情况：医学专家会遇到一些遭受慢性病痛折磨的人，他们做了所有的血液检查，检查了所有明显的生物学压力和疼痛迹象，结果却什么都没有。对此没有合理的解释。但随后这个人去接受了心理治疗。这个人开始谈论他们的愤怒，
starts talking about their resentment, starts talking about the pain of their past, and their physical condition improves. And these cases have always kind of shocked doctors because they're like, what are you talking about? Like, surely you must be taking some kind of medication. Surely you must be doing, it must be exercising differently. Something else must be happening. But the thing is that they were looking at chronic pain as purely a physical thing when at times it can be an emotional thing.
开始谈论他们的怨恨，开始谈论他们过去的痛苦，然后他们的身体状况就改善了。这些案例总是让医生感到震惊，因为他们会想，你在说什么？听着，你一定是在吃某种药。听着，你一定是在做，你一定是在做不同的锻炼。一定发生了别的事情。但事实是，他们一直把慢性病痛纯粹看作是一种生理问题，而有时它可能是一个情感问题。
When you hold onto a grudge, you constantly replay an offense. And all that rage, all that anger, all that fear and frustration and sadness, it comes rushing back to your body. And so your body is going to respond. as if you are in a perpetual ongoing state of threat. There is this very interesting idea that your body actually can't tell the difference between its imagination and what's happening in real time or an idea or a vision that you concoct for it and a real offense.
当你心怀记恨时，你就会不断重播一次冒犯。而所有的愤怒、所有的恼怒、所有的恐惧、挫折和悲伤，都会汹涌澎湃地回到你的身体里。所以你的身体就会做出反应，就好像你处于一种持续不断的威胁状态中。有一个非常有趣的观点，那就是你的身体实际上无法分辨自己的想象与现实中发生的事情，或者无法分辨你为它编造的想法、愿景与真实的冒犯。
And so just thinking about a previous grudge or a previous thing that happened to you that hurt you is equally as triggering as that thing happening to you right now. Because this relentlessly activates your fight or flight system, a very ancient stress response, you start to really feel it in your body. I know when I think back to, you know, a time that I was hurt. I feel it like in the center of my chest. I feel it like a balloon that it's getting so big in like my chest cavity that I can't burst it, but it won't go away.
因此，仅仅回想以前的记恨或以前发生在你身上伤害过你的事情，其触发效果与那件事此刻正在发生在你身上是完全一样的。因为这会无休止地激活你的战斗或逃跑系统（一种非常古老的压力反应），你开始真切地在身体里感受到它。我知道当我回想起自己曾经受到伤害的某个时刻时。我能感觉到它在我胸腔的正中央。我能感觉到它就像一个气球，在我的胸腔里越变越大，以至于我无法让它破裂，但它又不会消失。
Like it's a tightness. It's every single one of us can describe this pain. If you think about someone who has harmed you in the past, you feel a sudden tightness in your jaw, you feel adrenaline, you feel this rising in your chest. Like, there are physical reactions to things that we think only exist on an emotional plane. You know the phrase, holding onto anger is like drinking poison and expecting the other person to die? This is where it is incredibly relevant. In essence, carrying a grudge is keeping your body in a state of stress that it's only meant to be in temporarily. And we continue to keep it in that
就像是一种紧绷感。我们每一个人都能描述这种痛苦。如果你想起过去伤害过你的人，你会感到下巴突然紧绷，你会感到肾上腺素飙升，你会感到胸口有一股热流涌起。你看，那些我们原以为只存在于情感层面的事情，其实有着生理反应。你知道那句名言吗：怀恨在心就像自己喝下毒药却期待别人去死？这就是这句话极其贴切的地方。本质上，背负着记恨就是让你的身体保持在一种本该只是暂时的压力状态中。而我们却继续让它保持在这种
state for years. You think that by holding the memory of this past defense, you're hurting someone else or you're making sure they're not getting away with it, but they actually don't know how you're feeling. Like, you are not actually inflicting any kind of pain or suffering on them, because they don't know. You're the only person who is suffering is you. It's experienced solely by you. And beyond these physical impacts, you know, grudges also act as invisible emotional shackles because they involve such a great deal of rumination, this anchors us to a painful past and it actually affects our capacity to connect with new people. In one study published in 2021, research conducted very in-depth interviews with dozens of people
状态长达多年。你以为通过保留过去这次冒犯的记忆，你是在伤害别人，或者你是在确保他们无法逃脱惩罚，但实际上他们根本不知道你的感受。听着，你并没有对他们造成任何形式的痛苦或折磨，因为他们根本不知道。唯一在受苦的人只有你。这完全是由你一个人体验的。除了这些生理影响之外，你知道，记恨还充当着无形的心理枷锁，因为它们涉及大量的反刍思维，这把我们锚定在痛苦的过去，实际上影响了我们与新人建立连接的能力。在2021年发表的一项研究中，研究人员对几十人进行了深入访谈，
about the grudges they held and who they felt had harmed them in the past and they found that almost all of them had seen some lingering effect of this feeling on their current relationships, on their friendships, on their quality of life, and on how much they chose or could trust other people. Many of them also spoke about being trapped by their grudge. This emotional stuckness is often caused by this lack of resolution. You know, if a grievance is never communicated, or if an apology is never delivered, or if it feels unsatisfactory, the wound remains wide open. As humans, we are such weird little creatures in that we hate stories that don't have an ending. We just, we can't deal with it. That's why it's a whole genre of
内容关于他们怀恨在心的人，以及他们认为过去是谁伤害了他们，结果他们发现几乎所有人都看到这种感觉对他们当前的人际关系、友谊、生活质量，以及他们选择或能够信任他人的程度产生了挥之不去的深远影响。他们中的许多人还谈到了被自己的记恨所困。这种情感上的停滞往往是由缺乏解决方案造成的。你知道，如果从未表达过委屈，或者从未得到道歉，或者感觉道歉并不能令人满意，伤口就会一直大开着。作为人类，我们是非常奇怪的小生物，我们讨厌没有结局的故事。我们就是，我们无法应对。这就是为什么有那么多类型的
like uncomfortable TV and uncomfortable movies is movies that don't have endings because it just feels so like weird to us, very naturally weird. Holding a grudge is a story that has not ended. That is why it feels so emotionally painful. Even if they have died, even if we haven't seen them in years, that doesn't matter because to us, the world. still feels like it happened yesterday, that's what means we are unable to move on. Often when we experience these emotional reactions of suddenly being angry 10 years later, suddenly feeling a sense of or a desire for revenge months after the fact, when we feel that, we can be like, oh my God, I'm so immature.
让人难受的电视剧和让人难受的电影，就是那些没有结局的电影，因为对我们来说这感觉太奇怪了，非常自然地感到奇怪。记恨就是一个尚未结束的故事。这就是为什么它在情感上让人感觉如此痛苦。即使他们已经死了，即使我们已经多年没见过他们，这都无所谓，因为对我们来说，这个世界感觉就像是昨天刚发生的一样，这意味着我们无法释怀。通常，当我们经历这些情绪反应——比如10年后突然愤怒，事后几个月突然感到或渴望复仇时，当我们感受到这些时，我们可能会想：天哪，我怎么这么不成熟。
Why can't I just like let this go? Like, what's wrong with me? Am I a bad person? That's not the right way to think about it. this is actually a very valid and natural human response. It is a signal that a boundary has been crossed that an injustice has occurred. It's this thing though that it's not your fault, but now it has become your responsibility. And how you deal with it from here on now actually has nothing to do with the other person and everything to do with you and how you want
为什么我就不能放下这个？拜托，我怎么了？我是个坏人吗？这不是正确的思考方式。这实际上是一种非常有效且自然的人类反应。它是一个信号，表明界限已被跨越，不公正的事情已经发生。不过关键在于，这不是你的错，但现在它成了你的责任。而你从今以后如何处理这件事，实际上与另一个人毫无关系，它完全取决于你自己以及你希望如何
to continue living your life. Of course, this is absolutely easier said than done, especially if we haven't been taught how to do this, especially if there's unprocessed pain, especially if you think there is an ongoing threat. But we do have to learn how to shift this narrative from a grudge being about another person to being about ourselves. And we have to shift our ability to deal with a grudge from being like, this person needs to take responsibility, this person needs to feel pain, to I need to allow myself to feel peace and I actually owe it to myself to move beyond this in spite of them. We can start by firstly, like we've spoken about before, letting ourselves be angry.
继续过你的生活。当然，这绝对是说起来容易做起来难，尤其是如果我们没有被教导如何做到这一点，尤其是如果还有未处理的痛苦，尤其是如果你认为威胁依然存在。但我们确实必须学会将这种叙事从“记恨关乎他人”转变为“记恨关乎我们自己”。我们必须将应对记恨的能力从“这个人需要承担责任，这个人需要感到痛苦”，转变为“我需要让自己感到平静，尽管有他们在，我实际上也欠自己一个超越这一切的未来”。我们可以首先像之前谈过的那样，从允许自己生气开始。
Anger and rage have been painted as such impolite and dirty emotions. Like, they're a sign you can't emotionally regulate and they're a sign that, you know, you are just unbridled and you're going to go off at any given point. point. Actually, letting yourself feel angry is a sign of emotional regulation. Letting yourself just be upset in a safe way is how you stop an emotion from making its home inside of you and staying for decades. I think especially for women, I wish we would just let ourselves get fucking pissed every now and again and not try and silence what that might mean and not try and silence ourselves because we think it makes us a bad or an hinged person.
愤怒和狂怒一直被描绘成极其不礼貌和不干净的情绪。仿佛它们是你无法进行情绪调节的标志，仿佛它们表明你，你知道的，只是无法无天，随时都可能彻底爆发。实际上，让自己感到愤怒是情绪调节的一种标志。让自己以安全的方式感到心烦意乱，才是阻止一种情绪在你的内心安家并驻留几十年的方法。我认为，尤其是对于女性而言，我希望我们偶尔能让自己他妈的彻底发火一次，而不要试图压抑这种情绪可能代表的含义，也不要因为我们认为这会让自己成为一个糟糕的或情绪失控的人而试图让自己保持沉默。
There are plenty of ways to express anger in a way that is very productive, very healthy and very safe. Firstly, you can just scream it out. I remember when I was at university, there was this creek behind some of the old dorm rooms, like at my college on my campus. And at night, I have this distinct memory of me and my friends going down there. And I think one of, like, some guy I just broken up with one of my friends and we someone was dealing with some terrible man and some terrible teacher, whatever it was. And we just all like screamed. We just like screamed. I hope there was no one like walking around there who thought that we were distressed, but we were like we just got to let it out. And it's definitely like an angry scream, not a fearful screen. And it was
有很多方法可以以非常高效、非常健康且非常安全的方式表达愤怒。首先，你可以直接放声尖叫。我记得我在上大学的时候，在一些老宿舍楼的后面，也就是我所在的学院和校园里，有一条小溪。在夜里，我有这样一段清晰的记忆：我和朋友们一起去到那里。我想当时我的一个朋友刚和某个家伙分手，或者有人在应付某个糟糕的男人、某位糟糕的老师，无论具体是什么事。然后我们就一起放声尖叫。我们就像那样大喊大叫。我希望当时那里没有人在闲逛，以为我们遇到了什么痛苦的事，但我们当时的想法就是，我们必须把情绪宣泄出来。那绝对是一种愤怒的尖叫，而不是恐惧的尖叫。而且那种感觉
euphoric. It felt amazing. Like it felt like we were high. Boxing classes as well, such a good outlet. Manual labor. If your neighbor needs some yard work done, that is your opportunity. unity. Chopping wood, raking leaves, just like gives those feelings somewhere to go. Some therapists also recommend like full body shaking where you just let your body go loose and you dance wildly. They say that's a very effective strategy, uh, belting out angry songs in your car, ripping up cardboard, smashing ice, rage rooms. You've got to find your outlet. You have to get over this hurdle of not letting yourself feel the emotion before you can start to consider more complex pursuits like forgiveness, like moving forward, like forgetting, because you can never
飘飘欲仙。感觉棒极了。就像我们嗨了一样。拳击课也是如此，这是一个非常好的宣泄途径。体力劳动。如果你的邻居需要有人帮忙打理庭院，这就是你的机会。砍柴、扫落叶，只是给这些情绪一个宣泄的去处。一些治疗师还建议进行全身抖动，就是让你的身体彻底放松，然后疯狂地跳舞。他们说这是一种非常有效的策略，比如在车里大声吼唱愤怒的歌曲、撕碎硬纸板、砸冰块、发泄屋。你必须找到自己的宣泄出口。在你开始考虑更复杂的追求（比如原谅、向前看、遗忘）之前，你必须跨过“不让自己感受这种情绪”的这道坎，因为你永远无法
forgive if the emotion isn't ready to be let go or hasn't been released. Let's talk about forgiveness now. I feel like I've been dancing around this topic because I know it's somewhat controversial. I set this in our episode over on mantra, but there is still no consensus within our society about whether it's better to hold on forever, forgive but not forget. forgive and forget. No one really knows which camp is best. Personally, though, I've talked about this before. I think that forgiveness is a form of self-care.
在情绪还没准备好被放下或尚未得到释放之前去谈原谅。我们现在来谈谈原谅。我觉得我一直在绕着这个话题打转，因为我知道它多多少少有点争议。我在我们Mantra栏目的那一集里说过这个，但我们的社会目前对于到底是应该永远记恨、原谅但不忘记，还是原谅并遗忘，仍然没有达成共识。没有人真正知道哪种立场最好。不过就我个人而言，我之前也讨论过这一点。我认为原谅其实是一种自我关爱。
Even if it's not for everyone, for me, I see it as a way to address what is hurting me or what is hurting you without necessarily needing the other person to be involved, not even needing to know that you have forgiven them. psychologically, you know, forgiveness is a deliberate decision to release resentment, to release anger, to release the desire for retribution towards someone else for your own sake, not for their sake. Because you understand that the burden, I guess, for not forgiving is going to be greater. It's an internal shift from, I think, an emotional state that is dominated by punitive emotions,
即使这种做法并非适合所有人，但对我而言，我将其视为一种在不一定需要对方参与的情况下，去处理那些伤害了我或伤害了你的事情的方法，甚至不需要让对方知道你已经原谅了他们。从心理学角度来看，你知道的，原谅是一个深思熟虑的决定，是为了你自己的利益，而不是为了对方的利益，去释放怨恨、释放愤怒、释放对某人的报复心理。因为你明白，如果不去原谅，你所要承担的负担我想会更加沉重。这是一种内在的转变，从一个被惩罚性情绪主导的状态——
like anger and hatred and revenge to one characterized by more positive or at least neutral emotions like peace, the acceptance of reality and even in some cases like compassion. Now let's get very crystal clear that forgiveness is not condoning the offense. It is not excusing the person's actions. It's not erasing the memory of the discomfort that they caused. there is a big difference between forgiveness and reconciliation, right? Forgiveness is internal. Reconciliation is external.
比如愤怒、仇恨和复仇，转变为一种以更积极的、或者至少是中性的情绪为特征的状态，比如平静、接受现实，甚至在某些情况下还包括同情。现在我们要非常明确地认识到，原谅并不等于纵容过错。它不等于为这个人的行为开脱。它也不是抹去他们所带来的痛苦记忆。原谅和和解之间有很大的区别，对吧？原谅是内在的。和解是外在的。
You can totally forgive someone without ever having to interact with them again. In the cases of abuse, repeated betrayal, ongoing harm, forgiveness is perhaps a possible act. Reconciliation will maybe never be a possible act. That's their real difference here. Because your primary responsibility is always going to be your own safety and your own well-being and establishing healthy boundaries. It doesn't mean that what happened was okay
你完全可以原谅某人，而再也不需要与他们有任何互动。在遭遇虐待、反复背叛、持续伤害的情况下，原谅或许是一种可能做到的行为。而和解也许永远都不会是一种可能做到的行为。这才是它们真正的区别所在。因为你首要的责任永远是确保你自身的安全、你自身的福祉以及建立健康的边界。这并不意味着发生过的事情是可以接受的，
and it absolutely doesn't mean that you have to be friends with this person. It just means that you are allowing yourself to be okay with the fact that it did happen and you're releasing the burden of the grudge. Forgiveness also cannot be forced. If you're not ready or if the act of trying to forgive actually causes more distress, it's okay to wait or to focus on us.
而且绝对不意味着你必须和这个人做朋友。这仅仅意味着你允许自己去坦然面对事情确实已经发生了这一事实，并且你正在卸下心头积怨的包袱。原谅也是无法被勉强的。如果你还没有准备好，或者试图原谅这一行为实际上带来了更多的痛苦，那么先等待一段时间，或者先把精力集中在其他事情、
other things or other coping strategies first. I think it's irresponsible for someone to approach someone else's pain by saying there is a timeline for forgiveness and you are behind on that timeline when that person has an experience what you've been through. You may never forgive it all and that's okay, but it is a gift to yourself if it's one that you feel you're capable of delivering. And I hope you realize that if the time is ever right for you, if you ever want to forgive the other person,
或者其他应对策略上，这也是可以的。我认为，如果有人用“原谅是有时间期限的，而你在这个期限上已经落后了”这种态度去对待别人的痛苦，当这个人甚至没有经历过你所经历的一切时，这是极其不负责任的。你可能永远都不会原谅这一切，这也没关系，但如果你觉得自己有能力做到的话，原谅是对自己的一份馈赠。我希望你明白，如果对你而言时机成熟，如果你真的想要原谅对方，
they're not going to benefit from that. This isn't a gift for them. Like, again, it's a gift for you. There is this researcher. His name is Everett Worthington. He's a leading expert in forgiveness. And he really emphasizes that the essence of this is about finding peace from the pain of the past,
他们是不会从中受益的。这不是送给他们的礼物。就像我说的，这是送给你自己的礼物。有这样一位研究人员。他的名字叫埃弗雷特·沃辛顿（Everett Worthington）。他是原谅研究领域的顶尖专家。他特别强调，这其中的核心本质是从过去的痛苦中寻得平静，
not forgetting that it didn't happen or not pretending that it didn't happen. And research findings will at least, least tell you, it does improve how you're feeling and it can lessen the emotional pain. For example, a 2023 study looking into the effectiveness of an intervention to promote forgiveness randomly assigned 4,500 participants to either engage in exercises of rewriting their own story from their perspective or just to all out try and forgive someone else. And what they found was that the easiest way towards forgiveness is recognizing the role that you did not play in this happening.
而不是去忘记它没有发生，或者假装它没有发生。研究结果至少会告诉你，它确实能改善你的感觉，并且能够减轻情感上的痛苦。例如，2023年的一项研究探讨了旨在促进原谅的干预措施的有效性，该研究随机指派了4500名参与者，让他们要么参与从自己的视角重写自己故事的练习，要么就全力尝试去原谅别人。他们发现，通往原谅最简单的途径是认清你在这一事件中并未扮演的角色。
And recognizing that the story was written by someone else and rewriting it or rewriting the ending in a way that feels better for you. And research will constantly say, like, when we do it this way, when we focus on, I don't know whether there was a lesson in that, whether there was meaning for us, when we focus on the fact that we, had no responsibility in it. This is significantly linked to lower levels of anger, lower depressive symptoms, lower levels of anxiety, improvements to sleep, less stress, the sense of feeling lighter, all things that I think that we can advocate and that we want for ourselves. It also just frees up so much mental space to focus on other things. And it means that actually the other person hasn't won. They haven't won by being able to sit in your brain for longer than they deserve and to being able to make, you know, a home in your mind, you have won because
并且认识到这个故事是由别人书写的，然后去重写它，或者用一种让你感觉更好的方式重写结局。研究一再表明，当我们以这种方式去做，当我们专注于——我不知道其中是否包含某种教训，是否对我们有意义——当我们专注于这样一个事实：我们对此不承担任何责任。这与较低的愤怒水平、较低的抑郁症状、较低的焦虑水平、睡眠的改善、更少的压力、轻盈感有着显著的联系，所有这些，我认为都是我们所倡导的，也是我们为自己所渴望的。它还能腾出大量的心理空间来专注于其他事情。这意味着实际上对方并没有赢。他们没有赢在能够比应得的时间更长久地占据你的大脑，也没有赢在能够在你的心中安家落户，而你赢了，因为
they have done this terrible thing. You have accepted that you can never understand why they did that. And yet you have still chosen to choose peace. And that means you have won on a whole other dimension. At least, I guess that's kind of how I see it. So I think to give you a quick guide to how we actually do this. I think there will be good days. There will be bad days. First, the most foundational step isn't to force forgiveness. It's just to acknowledge that something happened and it's to acknowledge that it was unfair and that you do have anger towards it and just consciously kind of respect that that anger needs somewhere to go and that is completely valid. Next, be honest with yourself. When no one is watching, when no one is around you, do you feel like
他们做了这件极其糟糕的事。你已经接受了你永远无法理解他们为什么那样做。然而你依然选择追求平静。这意味着你在另一个维度上赢了。至少，我想我是这么看的。所以我想给你们一个快速的指南，告诉大家我们到底该如何做到这一点。我认为会有好日子。也会有坏日子。首先，最基础的步骤不是强迫自己去原谅。而只是承认某事确实发生了，并承认这并不公平，你对它确实心存愤怒，然后有意识地去尊重这种愤怒，明白它需要一个宣泄的出口，而且这种情绪是完全合情合理的。接下来，对自己诚实。当四下无人，当你身边没有别人的时候，你是否觉得
this emotion is actually making you feel better or is it making you feel worse? Do you feel like the energy you're pouring into holding this grudge is worthwhile? Is it consuming you? Or is there a part of you that does maybe want to live without it? Maybe part of that is also recognizing what the grudge has rubbed from you already. Recognizing this personal cost can also really help motivate you to find find on an approach that works. When we then start to ask ourselves, what does this grudge represent is where we really have those breakthroughs. You know, I've noticed that often a grudge isn't about the event itself, but it's about
这种情绪实际上让你感觉好一些了，还是让你感觉更糟了？你是否觉得你倾注在怀恨之中的精力是值得的？它是不是在吞噬你？还是说，你的内心深处其实也有一部分渴望摆脱它而生活？也许其中的一部分还包括去认清记恨已经从你身上剥夺了什么。认识到这种个人代价也能真正地激励你找到一种行之有效的方法。当我们接着开始问自己：“这个怨恨究竟代表了什么？”时，我们才会真正取得那些突破。你知道的，我注意到怨恨往往不是关于事件本身，而是关于
what it symbolizes. Someone rejects you, you hold a grudge against them, but it's not because they rejected you. it's because perhaps it touches on a deeper story. You're telling yourself about your worth, whether you deserve love. Maybe someone betrays you, and yes, that sucks, but the pain. really comes from the fact that you couldn't see it coming and maybe that means that you're not able to protect yourself and that you don't feel safe. Maybe someone bullied you as a child
它所象征的意义。有人拒绝了你，你对他们怀恨在心，但这不是因为他们拒绝了你，而是因为这或许触及了你关于自身价值、关于你是否值得被爱的更深层次的心路历程。也许有人背叛了你，是的，这很糟糕，但痛苦的根源其实在于你当初没能看穿它，也许这意味着你无法保护自己，而且你感到很不安全。也许有人在小时候霸凌过你，
and you couldn't let it go. It's not really about them. It's about the fact that maybe when you were younger you didn't feel protected and you didn't feel like you could help yourself. You know, there's always something beneath the surface. What is the story that the scroge is keeping alive about who you are, who you are as a person or who you have been. And here's a layer of forgiveness we often overlook, but this is where it's absolutely vital. We need to also in some ways forgive ourselves. When we hold grudges against others, we frequently, I think, also harbor a silent, corrosive grudge against ourselves. We might replay our own, I guess, role in the past hurt, even though we don't have a role, we might ask very agonizing questions like, oh, how did I let myself get treated like
而你一直无法释怀。这其实并不是关于他们。而是关于这样一个事实：也许当你更年轻的时候，你没有感到被保护，你觉得自己当时无能为力。你知道的，表象之下总有些别的东西。这个怨恨一直在维系着关于你是谁、你作为一个怎样的人或者你曾经是怎样的人的什么故事呢？这里还有一层我们经常忽视的原谅，但这是至关重要的。我们在某种程度上也需要原谅我们自己。当我们对他人心怀怨恨时，我认为我们往往也会对自身怀有一种无声的、具有腐蚀性的怨恨。我们可能会在脑海中反复回放自己在那场过去的伤害中所扮演的——我姑且这么说——角色，尽管我们其实根本没有扮演什么角色，我们可能会提出一些极其痛苦的问题，比如：“噢，我怎么会让自己受到这样的对待？”“我当时为什么不开口说话？”“我为什么会信任他们？”然而事实上，这种自我污染在这里毫无立足之地。你并不软弱，你并不愚蠢。这种对自己的苛责只会让你陷入困境，不仅让你深陷怨恨之中，而且还让你陷入一种毫无帮助的自责之中。对别人的原谅，
that? Why didn't I speak up? Why did I trust them? When in fact, like this self-contamination has no place here. Like, you were not weak, you were not foolish. This criticism towards yourself is getting you stuck, not just within the grudge, but it's getting you stuck in a place of self-blame that is not helpful. Forgiveness towards someone else, requires an act of kindness and understanding towards ourselves and recognizing that you did the best you could with the knowledge and the emotional resources that you had at the time. Finally, and this might sound controversial, I know I'm probably going to get pushed back, but ask yourself, if the roles were reversed, if this was me, would I want forgiveness?
需要对我们自己抱有一份善意和理解，并且要认识到，你当时已经凭借你所拥有的知识和情感资源做到了最好。最后，这听起来可能有点具争议性，我知道我可能会遭到反对，但问问自己：如果角色互换，如果这一切发生在我身上，我会渴望得到原谅吗？我会希望别人能够理解那些驱使某人做出这种事的种种原因、决定、或者仅仅是纯粹的愚蠢吗？如果是我做了这件事，我会希望别人原谅我吗？如果答案是肯定的，这是我们能得到的、最简单的答案，那么我想这种认知能够让你更容易对另一个人心怀慈悲，同时也对自己心怀慈悲。如果答案是否定的，那有时也会同样具有解放意义，因为它再次向你证实了你绝不可能变成他们那样的人。你绝不可能堕落到那个地步，因为你是有道德的、善良的、负责任的且优秀的。正因为你拥有这些特质而他们没有，所以你赢了。你正式成为了那个更好的人，句号。因此，你原谅他们并选择向前看，现在这是他们
Would I want someone to understand the reasons or decisions or just plain stupidity that drove someone to do this thing. If I had done this, would I want someone to forgive me? If the answer is yes, the easiest answer we can get, then I think that acknowledgement can make it easier for you to have compassion for that other person, but also compassion for yourself. If the answer is no, that's sometimes just as liberating, because it reconfirms that you could never be like them. You could never stoop that low because you are moral and kind and responsible and good. And because you possess those traits and they don't, you have won. You are officially the better person, full stop. And so you forgiving them and choosing to move on, that's something that they are now
欠你的人情了。你是格局更大的人，是更勇敢的人，你是赢家。你知道吗？我明白这听起来有点自负，但谁在乎呢？我认为，不管付出什么代价，只要能释放情感包袱，你就必须去做。怨恨，是的，它们让我们付出了代价。它们也是普遍存在的，而且是我们并不总能控制的东西。有一些深层的、古老的心理学机制想要让你困在一个糟糕的想法里、一个糟糕的记忆里、一段糟糕的时期里。但你同样拥有自主权和力量去重新思考这对自己是否有益，去重新思考：“嘿，这到底是在帮我还是在害我？”并做出那个决定。你知道的，尽管我给了你建议、表达了我的观点，但也许你就是不想原谅某人。
indebted to you for. You are the bigger person, the braver person, you are the winner. And you know what? I get that that sounds kind of egotistical, but who cares? I think whatever it takes to release the emotional burden, you must do it. grudges, yes, they cost us. They're also universal and there's something that we can't always control. There is some deep ancient psychology that wants to keep you trapped in a bad thought, in a bad memory, in a bad time. But you also have agency and you have power to rethink whether that is beneficial to you, rethink, hey, is this actually helping me or harming me? And making that decision. You know, as much as I have given you advice and I have opinions, maybe you don't want to
也许愤怒能给你提供动力。也许这种感觉挺好。也许你并不像其他人那样正在承受这件事带来的后果。如果真是这样，那完全没有问题。我认为这是一场极其私密且个人的对话，因为每个人的情况都会有所不同。但如果怨恨正在让你付出任何代价，我认为重要的是重新评估这是否是你想要放弃的东西，以及你是否愿意为这份怨恨付出代价，或者现在是时候把它放下了。所以我希望这能成为一个很好的引导，让你了解如何做到这一点，以及它背后的心理学原理。我懂你，我理解你。有些怨恨我至今仍在努力克服。我不知道。我前几天还在想这个。就像我七岁的时候，有
forgive someone. Maybe the anger fuels you. Maybe it feels nice. Maybe you aren't dealing with the consequences of this like other people are. And if that's the case, that's entirely okay. I think this is such an intimate and personal kind of conversation because it is going to differ for everyone. But if a grudge is costing you anything, I think it's important to reevaluate whether that's something you want to give up and whether you're willing to pay your dues to the grudge or it's time to let it go. So I hope this has been a nice introduction into how you can do that, into the psychology behind it. I feel you. I get you. There are grudges that I'm still trying to work through. I don't know. I was thinking about this the other day. Like when I was like seven, there was like this
一群女孩在我小时候霸凌过我，我前几天偶然见到了其中一个，我当时立刻就感到很生气，然后我想：“搞什么鬼？”那已经是二十年前的事了。这个人已经改变了很多。但怨恨是不理性的。所以，尽管我坐在这里夸夸其谈，但我自己依然有需要努力克服的问题。所以希望你们能明白，这些建议也是来自于一个并不完美、和你们一样在苦苦挣扎的人，
group of girls who bullied me as a kid and I like saw one of them the other day and I was immediately angry and I was like, what the heck? Like that was two decades ago. This person has changed a lot. but grudges are irrational. So as much as I'm sitting here preaching, there is still stuff I need to work on. And so hopefully you understand that this advice is also coming from someone who was imperfect and is struggling with just as much as you are,
但我希望我们能一起学到一些东西。如果你觉得其他人也需要听听这期节目，你也可以把它分享给他们。把它分享到你的Instagram上。如果你想给某人传递一个无声的信息，暗示你可能对某事还没有释怀——开玩笑的，这样做并不健康。也许还是别这么做了。
but I hope we were able to kind of learn something together. You can also share this episode with someone else if you feel like it's something they may need to hear. Share it to your Instagram. If you want to give someone a silent message that maybe you're not over something, just kidding, that's unhealthy. Maybe don't do that.
请确保在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你正在收听节目的任何平台上给我们留下五星好评。这确实对节目的成长、触达新听众非常有帮助。希望这一期节目能触达更多需要听到它的人。也许不会。也许它只会留在我们心里。但如果你已经听到了这里，请在下方留下一个小表情，代表怨恨对你而言意味着什么，它在你的身体里是什么感觉，在你的脑海里是什么感觉。有什么直观的方式可以让你把这种感觉表达或展现出来吗？我还要感谢我们的研究员伊丽莎白·科尔伯特（Elizabeth Colbert）对本期节目提供的协助。
And make sure you leave us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening. It really does help the show to grow, to reach new people. Hopefully this episode will reach more people who need to hear it. Maybe not. Maybe it just sticks with us. But if you have made it this far, leave a little emoji down below of what a grudge kind of represents to, what it feels like in your body, what it feels like in your mind. What's a visual way that you can kind of deliver that or show that feeling? I also want to thank Elizabeth Colbert, our researcher, for her assistance on this episode.
直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一些，我们很快就会再次聊聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人进行对话，带你超越统治健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油天生具有炎性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的
And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier,
人。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上的“TWO percent”。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）莉尔·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down and tried to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
我随时都可以一整天都在聊快克，只是为了让你们所有人知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆到台面上来了，所以。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的能量平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们去追求某样东西时，
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了那个东西。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯廷·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。你之所以是个好人，是因为你心怀恐惧吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
我希望你真的能纯粹地做一个好人。加入我吉尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real. conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她说法中惊人的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支由网络侦探组成的队伍来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一种令人不安的模式。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so on strike. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
另外两个经历过相同事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马拉奇尼（Michael Maranchini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Maranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness. fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上的“TWO percent”。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和说是个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
与我们的朋友、同仁喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是个疯狂的年代。那是个疯狂的年代。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人而言。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你正在收听由你最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人吉尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历的，进行一些坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界释放出一种信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去这样做，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
This space is about black men. experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支由网络侦探组成的队伍来揭露一种令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过相同事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮。迈克尔·马拉奇尼。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marantini.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Eyeheart. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我震撼得无以复加。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听播客《深陷爱河》。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。